how's it going everyone this is
international Master Daniel rench this
is chess.com and this is everything you
need to know to start playing chess
designed to be the first step for
players who do not know how to play the
game of chess and the everything you
need to know video lecture series you
made the first step toward mastering the
game of Kings when you signed up for a
membership on the greatest chess website
in the world that's chess.com
but the second equally as important step
is to learn how to play the game Let's
Jump Right In before we learn about the
battlefield in which we're going to be
playing the game of chesson and how the
pieces move and all the other basic
rules and principles we're going to take
out of this video lecture a little bit
of a history chess has been around for
as long as just about any other board
game with the earliest versions dating
back to 600 AD in Persia and India
believe it or not and the modern
versions of the game that we play today
let's say tournament chess have been
around since roughly the 15th centur
century and was popularized in Europe
the game of chess is played on a 64
Square checker board a board that
alternates between light and dark
colored squares you can say white and
green or in many cases white and black
but light and dark is the most common
terms used to describe the rotating or
alternating colors on a chess board
there's basic terminology that you need
to know in order to be a chess player
this will help you when reading
materials or watching video lectures on
our site as well as just the terms you
should use to describe the movements of
your own pieces the first one is rank
rank is a term we use to describe the
side to side Direction in chess this
being the sixth rank the fourth Rank and
here the second rank so on and so forth
the next term you need to know is file
file is a term we use to describe the up
and down directions of a chessboard with
this being the C file the first one I
highlighted being the E file the G file
the H file and so on and so forth the
third and final direction that any one
piece can move on a chessboard is a
diagonal diagonal is a term we use to
cut across the board like so with Rank
and file being the terms we use to
describe the straight up and down
lateral and longitude directions
diagonal is a side to side cutacross
Direction with this being the B1 H7
diagonal the H1 A8 diagonal the A2 to G8
diagonal and so on and so forth you've
noticed as I described the basic
terminology of rank file and diagonal I
was using the letters and and numbers
you see directly beneath and to the side
to the left of your chessboard these
numbers are known as algebraic
coordinance and they're used to write
down chest notation or to keep score on
a tournament game these letters and
numbers are used to help us keep track
of chess notation every move has an
address a note that can be recorded
every square has a location and a name
that we use to refer to it with this
Square being E6 this Square being C4
here we have G2 C7 B2 H5 and so on and
so forth notice that we always say the
letter first H and then the number five
whenever we're describing a chess board
or move a couple quick examples of how
we would write down a chess move here
The Rook is on C5 and if it moved to C7
we would use a capital R and then the
location that the piece landed on
currently this King resides on D3 and if
it moved to E4 we would write a capital
K and then write the square E4 for the
Knight though Knight starts with the
letter k we use n in chess as the K is
already reserved by the Royal Highness
in this case we would write n to E3
capital N E3 when it comes to moving the
pawn typically all you need to write is
the square the pawn lands on in this
case G5 as you see here some players
especially younger players when they
first learn the game like to use a
capital P as they use with the other
pieces in order to avoid confusion we
would use a capital B for Bishop and a
capital Q for Queen and so on and so
forth now that we've learned the basic
terminology used to describe the 64
Square Battlefield that we play the game
of Kings on let's meet all the players
and learn how a chessboard is set up to
its initial starting classical position
we will start first with his majesty
with the King starting always on the
opposite color square of their army with
the white king starting on a dark square
and the black king starting on a light
Square the position of the Kings is
always easy to remember when we learn
the starting position of the Queens as
the Queens are the opposite they must
always start on their own color with the
White Queen starting on a white square
and the black queen starting on a dark
Square continuing to move from the
center first toward the edge of the
board let's add the Bishops the
Protectors of the royal family here we
see the bishop start on F1 and C1 for
white and f8 and C8 for black next we
will add the knights the ponies the
noble steeds the knights start directly
between the Bishops and the last piece
we're going to add you'll see is the
Rooks the castles the towers of power
Knights start out for white on G1 and B1
and for black on G8 and B8 and finally
we see the towers of power bringing up
the rear starting on the edge of the
board the Rooks being the most powerful
pieces directly behind the queen they
start out on H1 and A1 for white h8 and
A8 for black finally we see the pawns
the little guys complete the setup of a
classical chess game all the pawns for
white start out on the second rank all
the pawns for Black start on the seventh
rank according to algebraic notation
before we move on to learning how the
pieces move there is one last important
piece of Chess terminology that everyone
needs to know when the board is set up
it is often referred to as being split
into two areas the king side and the
queen side the king side is everything
from the e file over to the H file
essentially the side of the board that
the King is closest to the queen side is
everything from the D file to the a file
essentially everything that the queen is
closest to this is important and as we
get into the later portions of this
video you'll notice that when we
describe castling there are options to
Castle both King side and queen side
remember this terminology as it'll help
you understand what authors are
referring to when they're describing
plans and strategies on certain areas of
the board now that we've learned how to
set up a chess board and we've met most
of the Players let's take a deeper look
into how each piece moves as well as
learn the value or let's say relative
value of each respective chess man each
chess piece has a given value and these
are to serve as guidelines as you make
decisions throughout every game you play
when introducing the pieces stating
their value and teaching their movements
each coach may have a different strategy
I like to teach what the easiest piece
to learn first and move backwards
towards the most complex you may be
surprised in which order that is first
let's start with the Rook here we see a
rook on e4 and we learned that the Rook
is a powerful piece that moves along the
straight lines of a chess boort the
straight lines we already learned are
the ranks and the files a rook can move
in One Direction at one time on a rank
or a file so in this position The Rook
has the option to move to any Square
along the E file and any Square along
the fourth rank as long as it is not
obstructed by its own army or the enemy
Army The Rook can move as far as he
wants in any One Direction on the
straight lines of the chessboard and he
is worth Five Points the bishop is in
many respects the polar opposite of The
Rook the bishop is not allowed to move
along the ranks or the files ever and
his only legal movement is along the
diagonal of the color it currently sits
on and this position for example this
bishop can move to any Square along the
B1 H7 diagonal or any Square along the
H1 A8 diagonal a bishop that starts on a
certain color as we learned with the
bishop starting on F1 and C1 must stay
on that color for the entire game as it
only moves diagonally and will never
have an option to move along a straight
line to change colors quickly as we
State the value of the Bishops here as
three points we will remind you that you
have two Bishops of each color to start
the game you have one Bishop on the dark
square and one Bishop on a light Square
both of these pieces will be stuck to
that color Square for the entire
remainder of a chess game the next and
perhaps easiest piece to understand is
her Royal Highness herself the Queen the
first lady of Chess essentially the
queen is a rook and Bishop combined she
moves along the files the ranks the
diagonals and as long as she is not
obstructed by any one of her own pieces
or one of the enemies her scope
extends to the Far Corners of the
chessboard on almost any Square that she
stands on the queen is worth nine points
essentially the cumulative sum of a rook
and Bishop as eight points plus an extra
one as the queen has the ability when
she moves like a rook to switch from a
light squared Bishop to a dark squared
Bishop so rather than being worth only
eight the queen is essentially worth
nine which is again one more Point
higher than the cumulative sum of the
rook and the bishop she's the most
powerful piece though not the most
valuable piece as we'll learn about the
King right now the king though Limited
in his Mobility is the most valuable
piece because he does not even have a
value it is can be said that the King is
worth Infinity the King is worth the
entire chess board some have even said
the King is worth more than your mother
totally joking just relax in any case
the king can only move in one square one
square at a time but in any One
Direction he chooses much like a queen
however limited by only one square at a
time the king could move from this
position to D5 to E5 to F5 and so on and
so forth the king of is the most
valuable piece because you are unable to
trade him it is not an option to trade
him for any other piece a king starts
the game and is one of the only piece is
guaranteed to be on the board when the
game is finished the king cannot be
traded but he can only be trapped that
is known as Checkmate which we'll get to
at the end of this video as the goal of
every chess game you play so again your
king is the most valuable piece you own
you can list him as valuable as the 64
Square battle field that you play on and
he moves it one square at a time in any
One Direction the final two pieces to
learn are perhaps the most tricky the
Knight is the one piece that does not
fall under the category of moving either
straight on a rank file or diagonal as
every other piece does the Knight has an
awkward movement that is often referred
to as a capital l or boot shape a knight
in the center of the board is best
placed because it has access to the
entire area of the board when the Knight
moves you can often draw two lines that
would look much like a boot or a capital
l so often that term is used when
teaching children how to play the game
as the can be a tricky piece to master
at first as you see the Knight does not
fall under the category of maintaining a
straight line when it moves it's sort of
awkward movement makes it even more
important than the other pieces that it
maintains the center as you can see
while our KN on e4 controlled up to
eight squares a knight on the corner of
the board or on the edge of the board
would only control up to two when
capturing a knight only captures a piece
that is on the landing Square its final
destination Square though a knight
because of its awkward movement has the
abil ability to hop over both his own
Army and the enemy Army you do not take
pieces you hop over this is often
confused for Checkers a knight for
example capturing this bishop on C5
would capture that Bishop because the
bishop resided on its final Landing
Square however even though the Knight
technically crossed over the path of the
Pawn on C4 when moving to this Square
the pawn on C4 is not captured remember
that here's another example we capture
the pawn on D2 and though we sort of
technically cross this E2 square with
the awkward of the night we do not take
squares or pieces that we hop over only
pieces that happen to reside on the
Final Destination Square for the night
the KN may also have the option of
taking the piece on F6 here the other
piece that falls under the highly tricky
category is the pawn pawns can move only
in One Direction only forward all the
time the most loyal servants in your
army they only look forward to attack
the enemy pawns move one square at a
time and that's it they capture
differently than they move which we'll
talk about in a second
but the one exception for a pawn to move
two squares is on the first move when
the pawn still resides along the second
rank or in Black's case the seventh rank
the pawn has the option though not the
obligation to move two squares many
people will start out a chess game
moving their pawns to squares as it's a
quicker way to advance their army and
develop you can see more information on
how to start a chess game in the
everything you need to know the opening
installment of this video series but
back to the pawns pawns move one square
at a time only forward all the time with
again the option to move two though not
the obligation on the first move pawns
are the only piece that capture
differently than they move as we see
here if both black pawns started by
moving two squares they would actually
be stuck with neither side having the
option to move until either a other
pieces came along to help or B another
piece came along to the side of it the
diagonal allowing for a capture a pawn
only captures one square at a time just
as it moves but it only captures
diagonally you cannot hop over another
Pawn that is in front of you this is not
Checkers and you can only capture if a
piece resides on the immediate Square to
the left or right of your Pawn the short
diagonal an example of Pawn capture
would be this with the white Pawn on e4
having the option to take both the
Knight on D5 as well as the work on F5
however not his counterpart on E5
meanwhile the black pawn has the option
to take the pawn on D4 diagonally but
not the option to take the pawn directly
in front of
him Pawn's only C capture diagonally
never forward and they are the only
piece that captures differently than
they move finally the most special thing
a pawn can do perhaps making up for the
fact that it's only worth one point in
value when compared to the other pieces
is to promote itself a palm promotion
occurs when it reaches the other side of
the board in White's case upon reaching
the eighth rank here we see that the
pawn has the ability to promote itself
to either a queen Rook bishop or Knight
you see that the only two pieces
unavailable for promotion are the king
as there's only one king there can only
be one leader and remaining a PA
itself you'll notice that black also has
the same option if he perhaps has a pawn
that reaches the first rank in this case
black has the option to choose between a
queen Rook bishop or Knight just as
white did most often you'll see a pawn
promotion occur with one side choosing a
queen however there are cases of under
promotion where you may choose to
promote to a rook Knight or Bishop now
that we've met everybody we know how to
set up a chess board we understand the
basic way to read a chessboard using the
algebraic coordinates we discussed and
we even know the basic terminology of
how to describe the movement of our
pieces it's time to learn the goal of a
chess game that is to Checkmate the
enemy King to follow here will be a few
different examples of check made and
first we must describe check check is
any position where the king is under
attack this case being an illegal
position as both the white and black
king are Under Fire this would never be
possible in a real game and his only
being used here to highlight a check on
both Kings with the Rook Moving Straight
would have the ability to capture the
black king and the bishop would have the
ability to capture the white king a king
capture is never possible as whenever a
king is in check he must find safety
before all else it is against the rules
to make any other move if the king is in
check we use Czech as a tool to
eventually trap the king and deliver
Checkmate the first example of Checkmate
we'll see is here one of the most
straightforward and simple examples of
Checkmate a support mate the queen is
delivering a check to the enemy King in
this way the black king has no safe
Square moving to f8 would remain in
check moving to h8 would remain in check
moving to F7 would remain in check and
moving to H7 would remain in check black
has no Escape square and cannot capture
the queen on G7 because she finds
herself protected or supported hence the
term support mate by her own King here
we see another Checkmate resulting in
the climax of a two Bishop technique
here we have the dark squared Bishop on
E5 attacking the king this King cannot
find safety on H7 or G8 H7 due to the
bishop on e4 and G8 due to the King on
F7 the black king is in check he is
trapped and has no Escape Route the game
is over though we could go on for a long
time showing you examples of check and
Checkmate and examples that are close
but not quite cheze or Checkmate to
summarize here are the three points when
a king is in check he must either one be
able to find safety himself by moving to
a safe and uncontrolled Square by the
enemy two be able to block the checking
piece by interposing with another piece
from his own army or three be able to
capture the attacking piece capture the
Checker as they say the piece that is
checking the king must be removed
blocked or the king must find safety
when neither one of those three things
is possible a normal check has just
become Checkmate and this is the goal of
every chance game you play before we
move on from Checkmate one thing we must
clarify especially for players first
learning the rules is the difference
between Checkmate and stalemate
Checkmate as you learned is when the
king is trapped he has no safe squares
and nobody from his army can help him
stalemate is when the king is trapped he
has no safe squares the difference is he
is not under attack in Checkmate in the
position we had earlier the black Bishop
the dark squore Bishop excuse me stood
on E5 and was delivering the final blow
of the king in this case with black to
move the king is still trapped cannot
find a safe Square however he is not on
Under Fire in this case the result would
change from a wind for white which is
what the result would be after Checkmate
to a draw a half a point this is
slightly confusing for players who first
learn the game as chess is one of the
only games that has an option result as
a tie most regular Sports you're
familiar with would move to sudden death
or overtime of some nature however chess
does have the option of a tie and
stalemate as you see here is the example
of a tie you've now learned everything
that you need to know in order to start
playing chess congratulations the basic
rule tools and terminology used to
describe a chess board as well as how to
set up the board and the goal of the
game are all you really need to know in
order to start playing and enjoying this
wonderful game however in order to have
truly completed your mission of knowing
all the rules in the ins and outs of a
chess game we must show you about the
two secret moves or special moves in
chess the first one has to do with the
Pawns in this case we talk about aant
French for in passing osant was a rule
invented somewhere around the 14th
century which was used as a counter rule
when they first gave pawns the ability
to move twice if white has established a
Pawn on the fifth Rank and only when
white has established a pawn in the
fifth rank if a black enemy Pawn in this
case either the H or F Pawn tries to
move by it in two moves we see that in
this way white has the option though
again not the obligation to capture this
Pawn as if it has moved only one you are
capturing this Pawn in passing as the
pawn passes you you have the right to
capture it as if it is moved one again
this rule makes sense when you
understand that it was invented as a way
to give another option once they allowed
pawns to begin Moving Two moves on the
first move which was not always the
option so in this way once again you see
that if a pawn tried to move by you in
two squares in one move you would have
the option to capture it as if it is
moved one noted should be that if the
pawn moved one square and you de you
neglected capture of the pawn by making
another move then the pawn moved to
Second Square you no longer have the
right to capture this Pawn on pant or in
passing as you had the option to capture
it a move before and you declined to do
so so again the definition of v pant is
that when a pawn moves two squares by
you from his starting position so in
White's case it only works if you have a
pawn established on the fifth rank you
have the option to capture it as if it
is moved only one though again not the
obligation if a pawn advances and you
neglect capture of this pawn and then
the pawn advances further neglecting to
capture you when he does so you no
longer have the right to on basant as
you had your opportunity to capture this
pawn and neglected to do so on basant is
a tricky and advanced Rule and is
something that many players don't learn
until they've played perhaps even up to
100 chess games the final special move
you need to know is the only move in
chess where you have the right and and
ability to move two pieces at once after
a natural set of developing moves is
played here white has the ability to
Castle that is to move the King two
squares and The Rook next to it and this
way the king is putting himself on the
king side and out of the way of the
center and in doing so he also brings
The Rook quickly into the game and we'll
learn in the opening portion of this
video series why it's good to Castle and
why bringing your pieces into the center
of the board is the best idea you can do
in this situation again it is the only
option the only time when you have the
ability to move two pieces at once the
king castles and The Rook immediately
follows it by Landing himself on the
Square directly to the left of the king
noted should be that you also have the
ability to Castle Queen side the system
is the same the king moves two squares
and The Rook lands himself on the Square
directly to the right of the king in
this case again we see that the king
moves two squares and The Rook will
automatically find himself on the right
side of the king castling is only
possible when you have not moved the
king or The Rook from their starting
positions remember that okay that's it
congratulations you now know everything
that you need to know in order to start
playing the wonderful game of chess we
hope you enjoy this video and we hope
that it can serve as the first step on
your road to chess Mastery we'll see you
around on chess.com
[Music]